okay in saturday Saturday morning good
morning Saturday morning we are going to
check out the delicious 39 we took the
stairs ready with my pills you got heels
on yeah okay with egg elevator gonna do
with you we're going to the Toronto food
festival no Toronto delicious and
delicious food festival in toronto to
try some food what do you want to try
what hoping is there I'm hoping for some
fudge about here that's that's the certs
maybe maybe we'll get some recipe ideas
when you're next Nina's next creation
okay before though before we can go to
delicious food first of all that's about
like a half an hour drive or something
we need to get some coffee okay here we
go what's a bee gees what's happening
okay okay this before the world blows up
ice cap
okay off to the bhutto so we made it
here in record time look at look at my
drink I thought I'd be done sitting in
traffic and it's full almost because we
use a different way we used Nina's Waze
app and see what's don't we see being a
typical man I felt like hey I know how
to get there for sure and and the Nina
pulls out her her app and we get there
in like half the time so so we're here
and we're not going to be able to taste
any of the food because I've got this
crazy sugary drink but we're gonna have
some fun here we go it's unlikely person
in the direction this is entering the
Hall egg he said holiday it's their
explain decided before we go in I've got
to give props to tim hortons they
changed their straw on their ice caps
this is red thing now but it's way
stronger so when you mix the drink it's
it's a lot easier and the straw doesn't
think so Nina will demonstrate because I
have a hand look look see the straw
doesn't Bend props to you Tim Hortons
amazing work these are the kinds of
things you learn on the Evan Carmichael
channel so we are here at the delicious
food festival
with all these famous people
thank you so Roger mooking we saw a lot
of on the cruise ship he's got this show
where he and this other guy
they have this show where they taste the
world's hottest foods and they're in
this kind of competition to see who can
last longer eating this really super
spicy foods he's here
maybe we'll find autograph holy cannoli
com what are we doing here we do fresh
authentic Italian all right very cool in
various ways okay you do the fresh belt
which is a lot of fun yeah we do the
sill your own okay you can ring the
cream home and make them fresh and we do
chip and dip products / no soggy cannoli
holy cannoli and then my favorite
favorite product is the cannoli cream
pie okay I didn't anywhere else cannoli
keep I like that's cool she'll base
Cheers that's yummy okay we're here at
el rincon mexicano CA and they've got
tacos from taco sauce
stripes of extra hot smoky hot where's
the mild stuff where's the Maya miles
stuff is the green stuff okay
some future salsa
come here
give it a try okay let's try that
go for it
very cool looking yummy
yeah yeah cheers get one out
too much
cheers it up yourself
well let go that's not attack you very
mild the Marlin is mild I feel like a go
up a level it helps to have the milk
from the ice cap to cover it after yeah
let's try the mile no this is medium
here we go cheers it up
what do you think guys
good
Vikram
I like the mile better whoo others a
little there's a kick at the end there
yeah
it's good it's yummy yeah there's a
thank-you banana Thank You raspberry
that I'm saying Nina's gotta get in on
what do you think Rick laughing I gotta
get in there you get interesting come on
the raspberries none of them are you
want to do the roxbury yes you got the
heels on yeah let's look at those heels
yeah let's do it all right so to
mediterranean flavors caramel and black
cherry we have two Greek Styles lemon or
coke I'm going caramel for sure the
choice would will you darling oh that's
a full-on sample man look at that you do
nice
Oh
never care about yoga tried the lemon
lemony oh my caramel we're here watching
somebody from the Martha Stewart channel
was on with her son in my Johnny doing a
demo director from ugly story and here's
the thing they're reading a magazine
Turkey's am with you sure you want to
make a turkey sandwich all right I'm
good for that I'm down friend Nina
turkey sandwich balls so she's stirring
with a smoothie recipe and Nia had a
great smoothie video that people seem to
like so see what she does with her
smoothies always
she's got a banana oh my banana I'm
sorry Nina soaking in the education baby
I like your smoothie recipe barest it
was way more interesting than this okay
what did you learn
nina got tired and bored so we're
leaving we're gonna keep exploring Pei
mussels
is it really
you're correct oh wow the sample it
smells really good what's this what's
the sauce on this really sweet Thai
chili okay
and turns up
oh yeah that's right we tied Chile where
can people learn more about this
discover Pei mussels com alright cool
one of my favorite snacks
the triscuit I know all these little so
we've tried all these ones these ones
are good the red bean is good sour cream
is good
sweet potatoes good but the one what's
the one that I always get get the sour
with the solid food no no no tomato
what's the other one the flavor basil
yes based on the sweeps yeah okay okay
you don't have that here that known ok
ok continue on
and I like the sauce oh not the meat
hold this for a second the meat is
delicious too anyway chef mark out to
get the job we're going to sample some
Ontario food what local Ontario food
this is big line up here we're going to
go stage by stage and see what we can
eat what are we learning what are we
learning
and cultivating in Ontario okay and our
purveyors all focus on
so the jellies and preserves
Jamie Kennedy's
the meats are from VG needs those are a
hundred percent elastin and no hormones
mm-hmm and the crackers are from the bar
cool these are a one time with a song on
honey
let's try to meet you take 120 good it's
coming
mm-hmm
yeah it's good jami kenney is good
pear cider two different types of Snyder
here
I playing with sweet pain
as well as our example
our designer that's our name
hmm
at our store which is going
let's try we track there I'll do apple
them yeah cheers why you already
finished yours
well that's good oh yeah I like the
Apple
like a pair better
you want me to get another pair for you
I got too excited about the apples get
too though ok continue on what's next
ooh maple syrup good how are you what
are we doing here syrup I do would you
buy your sort where do we buy but you
can with syrup and more than pancakes
tell us where we're going where are we
going to buy syrup you keep on at many
places on to you ok are you with the
specific company you represent all the
oh cool good job chatham cool is this is
this your stuff here no but related
let's try it out here it's okay this I
got your little one Cheers
hmm rook York oh that's good mm-hmm
what's your favorite thing to put serif
on ice cream oh very cool popcorn we got
some creative man so don't [ __ ]
waffles or something that's good recipes
what's your favorite thing to put maple
syrup are
water tards these are as awesome see now
we got to make a butter tart with maple
syrup hmm yeah thanks guys that was
great what are you guys doing
função pork nice
ok
ok
I love college
very cool oh good thank you
and it's good yeah imagine it with
cilantro yeah that's what I'm talking
about which is kimchi yeah
alright so what are we doing here
wow wow very cool
and you represent on your apples school
too
Apple squash
tell me huh
ventricle recipe what do we need to know
about Ontario apple growers
increase to the first we tourism
is it a big export yeah really
yeah Wow
but of course we saw here
yeah okay very yummy thank you this is
the best ever turkey chili I want to
talk to them about Turkey but they're
all busy working away okay well here's
one for you but how is it
is it turkey chili so what do we need to
know about Ontario turkey this is all
they're all Ontario birds yeah this is
our chili recipe this is more fat the
ground beef very high oh cool well it's
a cutting board oh that's cool Nina knew
what it was I had no idea I thought was
a mouse man or big coaster or something
that's cool small cutting board did you
know is a cutting what you knew right
you knew I had no idea now we're going
to learn about goat cheese is a contest
win the gift basket okay we don't do
that let's move on
what are we trying here orange and this
one is green
okay okay we have a whole foods close to
us
yeah like goat cheese cross wind farms
okay you like it which one did you try
the peppercorn and this one is as fruit
cranberry oh I don't want my big camera
friend okay each other
to go with one with red wine this is
pretty good better switch back
oh yeah this week was really good so
quick let's learn from the past to lose
that we talked to number one have
somebody who you can talk to write the
turkey place all three of them were so
busy working and putting up the samples
I didn't have anybody talking number two
no cheese place you're going to have
somebody
at the front
promote a product you got to have
someone who's willing to be on camera
right you're going to get some exposure
I want to promote Ontario goat cheese
give me someone who's willing to talk to
me about your goat cheese they were
going to continue on what do we need to
know about Ontario veal this is an
Ontario veal meatball yeah so served in
a rust intimate rustic tomato sauce yeah
also have that recipe in here okay it's
actually stuffed in this recipe these
ones right here just clean
then yummy
like a sauce what what is this cinnamon
honey butter cinnamon cinnamon honey
butter yes Sydney yeah i can't i can't
speak who are you with oh the honey's
honey bee honey is that accompany it
specifically its Ricky Dicky p honey
calm alright cool you mix out yourself
is out of BBQ sauces our family runs mmm
so you saw the like jars of that
very cool ontario beekeepers association
we had one it's amazing you got it all
here
where's your store cookstown all right
ok
is the place cool hey what you're
holding an award or something there
what's up what's the grand champion of
what the key painted pumpkins for taste
Oh
alright Dickie beat honey yeah I'm
exciting honey barbecue honey mustard
try the honey mustard
that's right
wait the whole thing oh no sorry I
didn't understand that those ones that
have a part of her
what's this
organic organic Council of it oh ok cool
oh nice Rob progressing we have yogurt
based sauce for our veggies and may have
Fieldgate organics
sausage cool
Nina likes the forks okay try it out
kale
and
kale chips are awesome
you put oil on it you bake it yeah and
then just in salt or what kind of
seasoning yeah amazing so do you
advocate for organic businesses or
what's your role remember based on
profit okay the entire birthday
have a really strong connection to
you can join us yeah jamendo job is to
promote organic Ontario
and health reforms to
the government's
very cool I want to try this one let's
read this one this is the she's into a
sausage cheers
oh yeah needs a little like sauce or
something about coming some awesome
ontario local products you Lena we're
here at sweet pop gourmet popcorn will
know where let's try that what do we
have okay
that's okay cool whatever the web
flavors have smores this is cinnamon
bottom you can play Minaj brownie okay
so what we do is we take Pablo desert
laborers even through internal decadent
coffee for fight stores yet noticed I
boss no we have your marshmallow rich
buzzin chocolate okay okay cool which
one are you going to go find father
s'mores what he does
No
you start the business two of us YY
popcorn
she's too big
sir
I want to go campaign now yeah it's
really good very cool thank you what do
we have Olivia's gay club Olivia's cake
pops go for Nina what kind is a vanilla
and
nice yummy oh I'm gonna have it all
right
oh you look great
yeah we try them they're yummy thank you
what's to me ice this is a
japanese-inspired I scissors okay we
have 40 paper so you can enjoy
Wow ok come on tell me
okay we have to go see white since okay
me as well ok in the van Gogh
is here so when you find it please to
real man okay
ok the little aftertaste of the mint
okay I'll depart giving a refreshing
after cincy okay
what's your favorite
okay hit me I'm up for green tea try it
yeah it is you try go for it all right
that's mine isn't that mine what did you
get o Sesame this means get to stop the
usage
okay okay
try to Sesame it's not ice cream right
it's it's soy soy right okay okay did
you start the company he started the
company all right very cool what what
motivated you to start this business
well I think we are
so that there's a space in the market
for the guys nada soy or coconut
so we have quite the
really have the flavor profile that
we're looking for okay so even though
we're gluten-free options for a dairy
queen that we do believe that the
flavors are full what do you think very
cool you're liking it alright cool and
you so most of the consumers or to the
restaurant business or whilst leave you
till right now okay and where can we
find you supermarkets right now okay
then in 20 mins okay cool thank you
it's a very dark
haha very good
who me i'm loving it
okay we're done we are we are full yeah
we're gonna go home that was great I
love meeting on the local entrepreneurs
China on the local food with a belly
full of food and we're going to continue
on with our date so guys yet to tell
what your favorite here oh that's a good
idea what was your favorite I like the
muscle Muslims The Pianist the pei
mussels were pretty special
mr.
oh the jamie oliver's kitchen pepperoni
yeah that was good
gucci gucci is okay the muscles were
fantastic hey muscles are part of the
best must wither it was it was shocking
it was just shocking you weren't
expecting that kind of flavor in tasting
let's get together again I'll let the
popcorn it was good if I'm know is yummy
and I like the ice cream yes oh you guys
can we still finishing up and I felt
that guy's passion nice again how the
real because what it really should
that's why it should taste like yeah oh
yeah the honey the honey was really good
that's funny because I don't even know
what was happening the guy oh this guy
just threw these cracks in front of us
what's happening what is this where are
we but they were good yeah that was
really good maybe we should go to that
opening yep yes anyway ok that's it
wraps up a fun day you guys like this
video let us know what you think leave a
comment leave a comment for Nina and
subscribe to the channel believe we'll
see you soon don't forget to click here
to subscribe to my newsletter to get
actionable inspiring motivational
believe advice every single week to your
inbox hi i'm jason j reyez fonseka of
ra's online com and i want to say Evan
Carmichael's newsletter is consistent on
inspiring and XD only newsletter i
prioritize and look forward to period